When words just aren't enough,...
...say it with bacon.
Fall in love with the original strip.
Bacon.
Is there any meat more noble?
There isn't.
What is superior flavor but the marriage of perfection and how something tastes.
I always challenge my team to cut smarter...
...because every strip of bacon has its own unique symmetry, like a snowflake.
The bacon, it will tell you how it wants to be cut.
All you have to do is listen and the bacon will show you the way.
Nature, she provides the bacon strip,...
...but our cure perfects it.
Because while liquid smoke says, "I'm not that into you,"...
...real, hardwood smoke says, "Take me to the symphony."
Cut, color, cure, consistency.
These are the four facets of the Oscar Mayer Original Strip.
When it's time for the ultimate expression of love, say it on a plate.
Give a gift from the Oscar Mayer Original Collection.
Available for a limited time only at sayitwithbacon.com